Oh, bin ich am Start.
Steiner Adler.
Fünf, wohlgemerkt.
Dankeschön für den Zap.
Das ist sehr exzellent.
Es kann übrigens sein,
ich sage euch aber auch,
dass das nicht sonderlich wahrscheinlich ist.
Allerdings, es kann sein,
dass ich weg muss im Stream.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Weil ich habe heute Nacht
beziehungsweise heute Abend
und heute Nacht bis morgen früh
Rufbereitschaft.
Also kann sein,
wenn irgendwas ganz
gravierendes kaputt geht,
dass mich dann irgendeiner anruft
oder zumindest,
dass unser Monitoring-System
irgendeine Nachricht schickt,
die ich dann gucken muss.
Aber es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Im Großen und Ganzen
läuft das erstaunlich fehlerfrei
für das, wie viel Wildwuchs wir haben.
Also machen wir mal eine Runde Präge,
dass das nicht vorkommt,
nicht nur, wo man pennen kann.
Auf der anderen Seite,
so schlecht ist das auch gar nicht,
wenn was ist nachts,
weil man muss ja elf Stunden Abstand halten
zwischen letztem Einsatz und Arbeitsbeginn.
Und den Rest der Zeit kriegt man aufgefüllt.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
wenn ich nachts Einsatz habe,
kriege ich quasi fast einen Arbeitstag gratis.
Fast.
Gibt es den Friseur noch?
Ja, der Friseur hat gestern oder vorgestern
irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
sechs Stunden oder so
Gears 4 gestreamt.
Gears 5, glaube ich, sind sie gerade.
Ja, ich würde ja auch gerne,
also allgemein muss ich überhaupt mal
erstmal wieder ein Video machen.
Aber ich würde ja seit Jahren
schon mal gerne wieder mit dem Friseur
was aufnehmen.
Und ich weiß, der Fabian,
der will eigentlich, will der das auch.
Aber der kann sich immer nicht durchringen
dazu, das zu machen.
Ja.
Aber mal gucken.
Vielleicht gibt es, vielleicht gibt es ja demnächst.
Eins.
2012 YouTube.
Also, ich gebe dir recht,
ich hätte 2012 YouTube gerne zurück.
Allerdings ohne, dass ich Call of Duty Content machen muss,
dann auch wieder zwangsläufig.
Weil da hätte ich jetzt mit dem Ganzen
nach all den Jahren ja auch keinen Bock mehr.
Aber YouTube könnte durchaus ein bisschen wieder sein wie 2012.
Ich kann dieses ganze super gehypete,
diese Influencer Sachen, damals gab es das Wort Influencer noch nicht mal.
Ich kann das, kann mir das alles, alles.
Ich bin, bin da zu alt für mittlerweile.
Das war früher nicht ganz so schlimm.
Heute ist es ja,
ne Ahnung, heute muss, muss sich ja jeder wegen jedem Shit
erst mal drei Stunden entschuldigen.
Und es posten sogar irgendwelche Werbepartner,
öffentliche Statements, das ist alles so gestört mittlerweile.
Ich verfolge das nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich, mich interessiert das auch nicht.
Ich kenne die meisten Leute noch nicht mal,
die an irgendwelchen Beefs beteiligt sind.
Jetzt ohne Scheiß, ich kenne die nicht.
Ich habe von denen schon mal was gehört, von den meisten, ja.
Weil ich bin ja immerhin irgendwo noch ein bisschen auf YouTube
und ich gucke auch auf Twitter rum und das eine oder andere kriegt man mit.
Aber ich kenne in Form von, ich habe schon mal den Stream gesehen
oder Videos geguckt oder gar nicht, null.
Ich kenne die alle nicht.
Ich kenne die vom Namen her, aber ich weiß null,
was die für ein Konrad machen.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Der einzige Beef, den ich ein bisschen mitverfolgt habe,
weil ich es super lustig fand, war KuchenTV vs. Shoryoka.
Das war YouTube Beef and its best.
Das war schon wieder lustig, so bescheuert war das.
Aber den ganzen anderen Klempel, der ist mir vollkommen egal.
Der geht mir auch so richtig am Arsch vorbei.
Ich will das gar nicht sehen.
Ja, das ist wirklich so.
Ja, ja, ja, machen wir jetzt nicht.
Wobei, wenn ich YouTube in einem privaten Tab aufmache,
da kommt ganz viel Fußball immer.
Scheinen in Deutschland eben viele zu interessieren.
Ach ja, nice.
Nice.
Aber nicht im offiziellen, oder?
Aber nicht im offiziellen App Store.
Im offiziell-inoffiziellen.
Ach doch, ja, okay.
Ich frage mich, wie das ist.
Gibt es gescheiten Controller-Input für iPhones?
Weil du kannst diese ganzen Games ja ohne einen gescheiten Controller gar nicht richtig spielen.
Genauso wie Leute, die einen N64-Emulator da drauflaufen haben.
Ist ja schön und gut, dass es läuft.
Aber ich möchte trotzdem nicht N64-Spiele mit Touchscreen spielen müssen.
Und auch nicht mit emulated Analogstick auf dem Display und so.
Das ist ja beim Mobile-Game schon Schrott.
Ja, geht das?
Habe ich nie ausprobiert, aber wenn das geht, ist gut.
Dann passt es.
Ja, ja, dann ist gut.
Wenn das geht, ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert.
Das wäre der Friseur.
Klar streamt der auf Twitch.
Der heißt jetzt nur aus irgendwelchen Gründen anders.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Das hier ist er.
Ja, E-Mail-Adresse liegt.
Die ich immer nicht nur für Fake-Account-Registrierung verwendet habe.
Der hat aber irgendwie die letzten Broadcasts nicht aktiv.
Der war wie...
Wie gesagt, gestern oder vorgestern war der on.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Was da geht.
Aber er ist auf jeden Fall noch am Start, wie er früher immer so gesagt hat.
Der hat sich mehrere Stunden mit Gears of War zurückgemeldet, ja.
Wir haben mal kurz Package-Updates.
Übrigens, soll ich euch mal was ganz Tolles von Vodafone erzählen?
Wusstet ihr das?
Ich warte mal, bis meine VM an ist.
Dann kann ich euch in der VM zeigen.
Wusstet ihr, dass Vodafone Super-WLAN hat?
Super-WLAN.
Wurde ich letztens darauf hingewiesen.
Vodafone Super-WLAN.
Und was meint ihr, ohne nachzugucken?
Ohne nachzugucken, okay?
Was meint ihr, was Super-WLAN ist?
Es ist...
Ich kann euch jetzt schon spoilern.
Es ist nichts Besonderes.
Wi-Fi 7, 5...
Nein, nein, nein, Leute.
Leute, ihr denkt viel zu kompliziert.
Ihr denkt viel zu...
Super-WLAN ist nichts anderes wie die Funktion,
die so gut wie jeder andere...
nicht super low budget access point beherrscht.
Nämlich, sich einen möglichst unbenutzten WLAN-Channel raussuchen.
Das ist alles.
Das ist Super-WLAN.
Und das kannst du dir irgendwie zusätzlich irgendwie buchen und sowas.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung.
Okay, kostenlos, ja.
Mesh-System, ist klar.
Mesh-System, Mesh-System.
Einer mehr.
Aber der Name ist schon mal toll, oder?
Ja.
Übrigens zum Thema Marketing.
Ja, ich hatte heute auf der Arbeit irgendjemand von, frag mich nicht,
von der Marketing-Abteilung in einem Teams-Call.
Und die haben die ganze Zeit irgendwas erzählt mit...
Ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen.
Irgendwas mit Liefervereinbarung oder Ergebnisse.
Oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Und da hab ich die gefragt, ist das nicht so, dass das...
Also, ich muss dazugehen, ich weiß das.
Aus meiner YouTube-Seite.
Aus meiner YouTube-Geschichte.
Und die ein oder anderen Sponsor- und Werbesachen, die ich dort gemacht hab, ja.
Also, ich kenn so ein paar richtig sinnlose Marketingbegriffe.
Ich will damit zwar nichts zu tun haben, aber die ein oder anderen kenne ich, ja.
Und da hab ich die gefragt, sagt man da heute nicht, wenn man im Trend sein will, Deliverables dazu?
Ich kann das nicht richtig aussprechen, aber die wussten bestimmt, was ich meine.
Aber wir sind so oldschool, dass wir nicht die coolen, trendy Marketingwörter verwenden,
sondern wir suchen irgendwelche deutschen Übersetzungen.
Also, Leute, merkt euch das.
Wenn ihr mal bei Marketingleuten irgendwie so tun wollt, als habt ihr Ahnung.
Das nennt sich Deliverables.
Also, wenn's drum geht, beispielsweise ihr macht irgendein Sponsoring und der Typ oder irgendeine Werbeplatzierung,
was der Typ euch liefern muss, ja.
Oder was ihr liefern müsst.
Die coolen Leute nennen das Deliverables.
Und nicht irgendwie Lieferergebnisse oder Ziele oder whatever.
Deliverables nennen das die coolen Leute.
Aber wir wollten nicht.
Da sind wir zu oldschool für.
Ach ja, wirklich?
Ja?
Was mach ich jetzt mit meinem Lizenz-Key?
Ich will aber nicht upgraden.
Das ist aber sehr nice.
Ich will aber nicht upgraden, weil das letzte VMware-Zeug ziemlich kaputt ist.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das sehr gut.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das wirklich sehr gut, dass das jetzt kostenlos ist.
Es gibt eigentlich gar keinen Grund mehr für VirtualBox.
Leider hat VMware in den letzten Jahren an Workstation auch schon relativ wenig gemacht.
Und ich fürchte, jetzt damit wird da wahrscheinlich noch weniger dran gemacht.
Dabei ist Desktop eine gute Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Legit eines der wichtigsten Anwendungsfälle für mich, die es abzudecken gilt.
Und da gibt es ja eigentlich nur VirtualBox und VMware Workstation.
Was gibt es denn da sonst noch?
Mir fällt nichts ein.
Ja, wir müssen uns eh überall registrieren.
Wir müssen auch für jedes Game einen eigenen Launcher installieren.
Und einen eigenen Pups-Account bei... frag mich nicht...
mypups.com oder whatever machen.
Damit wir uns das Game installieren können.
Was sagst du zu Google?
Ich habe nichts damit... gar nichts davon verfolgt.
Auf jeden Fall posten.
Da gibt es schon genug Keys.
Da muss meiner nicht auch noch hin.
Jetzt mache ich meine Package-Updates. Ich wollte doch Package-Updates machen.
Habe ich das jetzt gemacht oder nicht?
Oder habe ich es verpeilt?
Ja, ich habe es verpeilt. Keine Package-Updates.
Aber das brauchen wir heute nicht.
Ja, es ist kurz vor der Vollendung, dass ich mein Geld bekomme.
Ich habe gestern vom Anwalt den Brief bekommen.
Die haben jetzt alles bezahlt und jetzt kommt der Ha...
Also diese Versicherungen, die sind so unglaublich unfähig.
Die haben jetzt sogar zu viel Geld überwiesen.
Und das ist ihnen den Tag später aufgefallen.
Und jetzt wollen sie 80 Euro noch zurück haben.
Allein schon, der Schriftverkehr mit meinem Anwalt kostet jetzt mehr als 80 Euro.
Also Fachkräftemangel scheint da wirklich ein Ding zu sein.
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist in letzten Zügen.
Also ich müsste das Geld entweder heute, morgen oder übermorgen, irgendwann demnächst auf dem Konto haben.
Auf der anderen Seite, ganz im Ernst, auf die paar Tage kommt es jetzt auch nicht an.
Auf die paar Tage kommt es jetzt auch nicht an.
Es ist eh lächerlich, dass es überhaupt erlaubt ist, so lange zu brauchen, das alles zu überweisen.
Auf der anderen Seite, irgendwie ist mir das auch egal.
Ich habe eh mir mittlerweile ein neues Fahrrad gekauft.
Und das jetzt früher oder später kommt...
Was?
Kein E-Bike.
Das Fahrrad hier, guck mal.
Habe ich das nicht mal gespeichert?
Ich habe doch...
Wir hatten doch...
Wir hatten mal ein Kommando, oder?
Ausrufzeichen Fahrrad.
Ja.
Moment, das ist das falsche.
Das ist das falsche Kommando.
Weil das gibt es nicht mehr.
Hatten wir das nicht?
Hatten wir das nicht geupdatet auf den Internetarchiv?
Link?
Wir hatten doch...
Moment, Moment.
Wenn nicht, müssen wir das gerade mal kurz machen.
Ich suche das mal raus.
Archiv.
Org.
Ja, das war der richtige, aber ich bilde mir ein, wir haben es letztens...
Wir haben es letztens schon geupdatet auf...
Auf das Internetarchiv.
Wenn nicht, können wir das jetzt schnell machen.
Ich poste das mal kurz rein.
Ja.
Das ist mein Fahrrad.
Kein E-Bike.
Gucken wir mal, ob man die Ausstattung ausklappen kann hier unten.
Ja, kann man.
Sehr gut.
Ja, dann kann man das verlinken.
Einzige Sache, die ich modifiziert habe, ist das hier.
Ich habe hinten nicht 11 bis 34 drauf.
Ich habe hinten 11 bis 40 drauf.
Ja.
Habe ich umgebaut.
Ah ja, und was ich auch noch gemacht habe ist, ich habe alles entfettet und die Kette gewaxt.
Hört sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen anstößig an, aber ich meine es wortwörtlich.
Und das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Eine gewaxte Kette.
So, wir haben Package-Updates gemacht.
Reboot.
Mein Anwalt sicherlich mehr.
Ich kann es dir noch nicht genau sagen.
Ich kann es euch erzählen, wenn ich das Geld auf dem Konto habe.
Mein Gewinn habe ich ja gar keinen gemacht, in dem Sinn.
Wenn schon, habe ich Ausfallentschädigung oder wie das heißt bekommen.
Also, sich mal vorstellen.
Ich hatte letztes Jahr im, weiß ich, Oktober oder so den Unfall.
Und die haben es jetzt, schaffen sie es vielleicht, Mai.
Oktober, November, Dezember, Januar, Februar, März, April, Mai.
Das hat über ein halbes Jahr gebraucht.
Ja, irgendwie so.
Kette wachsen ist gerade in Mode.
Ich glaube, es ist mittlerweile easy genug, dass es viele Leute zu Hause machen.
Ja, da hast du verloren.
Finanzamt ist eh das geilste, was Überweisungen angeht.
Die brauchen teilweise ewig, bis die irgendwas auf die Reihe kriegen.
Aber wenn du einen Zettel kriegst.
Steht immer schon hinten gleich drauf, was dir droht.
Rechtsbelehrung.
Und dann hier.
Ja, ich habe doch hier gerade wieder was liegen von denen.
Andernfalls zahlen sie bitte die rückständigen Steuern bzw. Abgaben innerhalb einer Woche.
Bam.
Die können aber ewig brauchen.
Das eine hat ja mit dem anderen nichts zu tun.
Also, wenn ich denen was überweisen muss, dann muss ich denen was überweisen.
Ich könnte denen natürlich eine Einzugsermächtigung geben.
Mal kurz was gucken.
Ich muss gucken, ob die Überweisung ans Finanzamt auch wirklich raus ist.
Weil ich habe keinen Bock, da irgendwie Mahngebühren oder sonst was zu bezahlen.
Was ist denn?
Today? Yesterday?
Ja, Finanzamt. Okay.
Die Zahlung ist raus.
Als Instant-Überweisung.
Wow.
Lohn und Gehalt ist eingetroffen.
Heute sehe ich gerade.
Nice.
Da freut man sich doch immer.
Exzellent.
Ach so.
Ja, da hast du gelitten.
Da hast du Pech.
Da wurde schon alles, wenn du vom Urlaub wiederkommst, wurde schon alles gefendet, was bei dir im Hof auffindbar ist oder so.
Max, bin nun acht Monate in meiner Ausbildung Systemintegrator.
Habe aber keinen Plan, was ich nach der Ausbildung machen will.
Mach dir keinen Kopf, das geht noch eine ganze Weile.
Acht Monate ist ja gerade erst mal richtig, noch nicht mal richtig akklimatisiert.
Mach dir mal keine Gedanken. Mach erst mal in Ruhe.
Zwei Jahre deine Ausbildung, ja?
Ja, macht doch nichts.
Mach mal zwei Jahre deine Ausbildung in Ruhe.
Und mach dir nicht von Anfang an so viele Gedanken.
Was hältst du von der Schweiz? Vielleicht irgendwann mal sein Glück dort probieren?
Wenn ich ein gutes Angebot kriege von einer Firma aus der Schweiz, was sich im Endeffekt lohnt.
Und der Berücksichtigung aller Sachen, die man da so berücksichtigen muss, die ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht weiß, aber mich dann schlau machen muss.
Ja, klar. Warum nicht?
Ich würde jetzt nicht aktiv danach gucken, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber mal angenommen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen kommt dann eine Schweizer Firma und sagt, Max, wir brauchen genau dich für die und die Sache.
Ich finde die und die Sache ist auch ganz toll.
Und wir bezahlen auch mega viel Kohle.
Bei uns ist alles furchtbar geil und Homeoffice und whatever.
Dann hätte ich keine Probleme, auch zu einer Schweizer Firma zu gehen.
Hast du Tipps, wie man das passte Thema Unternehmen für die Abschlussarbeit findet?
Bachelor-Informat? Keine Ahnung.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass für deine Bachelor-Abschlussarbeit etwas höhere Maßstäbe angelegt werden, als für ein FISI-Abschlussprojekt.
Dementsprechend...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nachdem ich keine Informatik studiert habe und das nicht selbst...
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann dir sagen, wie du dein FISI-Abschlussprojekt aufbaust, dass die IHK das mag.
Aber was du da machen musst, fehlt mir selbst die Erfahrung.
Hey Max, angefangen Informatik zu studieren.
Ich tippe 40 Wörter pro Minute, sollte ich da schneller sein.
Ist vollkommen egal, wie schnell du tippst.
Du wirst mit der Zeit und der Übung schneller.
Du wirst irgendwann auch feststellen.
Du musst gar keine Wörter mehr ausschreiben, wenn du dich ordentlich auf der Kommandozeile auskennst.
Und außerdem...
Es kommt viel mehr darauf an, was du tippst, als dass du es jetzt übermäßig schnell tippst.
Das ist genau das.
Das ist so ein Argument, was ich nie verstehe.
Die ganzen WIM-Enjoyer...
Also ich meine, ich benutze WIM auch täglich.
Einfach, weil es der beste Editor ist auf der Kommandozeile und es auf jedem System drauf ist.
Und weil man viel per SSH unterwegs ist.
Aber die ganzen WIM-Enjoyer...
Wenn ich die da immer argumentieren höre...
Ja, WIM, da hast du immer deine Finger auf der Home-Row.
Und die schnellste Time von Brain to Keyboard und sowas in der Richtung.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie ihr programmiert.
Aber bei mir ist Programmieren, sagen wir mal, mindestens 50% überlegen.
Und 50% tippen.
Realistisch betrachtet sind es wahrscheinlich eher 80% überlegen.
Und 20% tippen.
Und ob du die 20% jetzt immer so in, keine Ahnung, 3 Sekunden Burst schreibst...
Oder ob du da ein bisschen langsamer bist, macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Ich kann jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht einordnen, wie schnell 40 Wörter pro Minute sind.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel ich hinkriege.
Ich habe das irgendwann mal ausprobiert.
Aber das Ding ist, selbst wenn ich es jetzt teste, ist mein Ergebnis wahrscheinlich sehr schlecht.
Weil ich zig Schreibfehler mache, was nicht weiter wild ist auf der Kommandozeile.
Weil die meisten Sachen kompliete ich eh aus der History und Änderung.
Da passiert nicht so viel.
Und im Zweifelsfall geht das Kommando nicht.
Oder wenn es Teams ist, dann habe ich zur Not Auto korrekt oder schick es einfach so ab.
Also ich korrigiere nicht jeden Schreibfehler.
Ja, bei mir auch.
Ja, ist genauso.
Meinung zum Einsatz von KI beim Programmieren, insbesondere GPT-4, mir fehlt...
Was fehlt dir enorm?
GPT-4?
Achso, dir gefällt das?
Ja.
Also ich glaube, du nutzt das genau fürs Richtige.
Das ist das, wofür ich es auch benutzen würde.
So als Denkanstoß.
Und zum Überprüfen, also wo ich das ganz gerne verwende, ist, wenn du irgendwie...
Beispielsweise, du hast irgendwie ein riesiges Ansible gedönst.
Ja.
Und genau hast, was das macht.
Und irgendwie ist halt die Dateiberechtigung auf einer Datei falsch am Ende vom Ausführen, ja.
Und du findest es einfach nicht.
Da kannst du das bei ChatGPT reinpacen und sagst hier, warum hat die Datei...
Keine Ahnung, 755 soll aber 700 haben oder so.
Für sowas ist ChatGPT ganz gut.
Auch um Syntaxfehler zu finden.
Wohlgemerkt, Syntaxfehler in YAML-Files ist ChatGPT ganz gut.
Weil ihr kennt das vielleicht, YAML-Files haben ja streng genommen eigentlich kaum Syntaxfehler.
Aber sie sind trotzdem falsch.
Logisch.
Weil sie sind nicht syntaktisch falsch.
Weil es könnte ja ein neuer Block mit Einrückung sein.
Aber sie sind logisch falsch.
Weil der Block an der falschen Stelle ist.
Es funktioniert halt einfach nicht.
Also für YAML zum Suchen, was da nicht richtig eingerichtet...
Wie das, warum das vielleicht verkehrt sein...
Da ist ChatGPT auch ganz gut.
Ja klar.
Ja, es ist viel besser als ein YAML-Parser.
Ein YAML-Parser kann dir sagen, dein YAML ist syntaktisch korrekt.
Dass du aber einen Block falsch eingerückt hast, das checkt ein YAML-Parser nicht.
So, und...
Ansonsten muss ich sagen, ist ChatGPT bei mir von Anfang an ein bisschen unten durch gewesen.
Seit ich das das erste Mal ausprobiert habe.
Weil es hat so krass reingeschissen, ChatGPT.
Bei meiner Übungsaufgabe, die ich mal gepostet habe.
Das war doch ChatGPT 3, 5 wohlgemerkt.
Als das ganz neu war, habe ich gesagt, ey, guck mal, das halbe Internet ist am ausflippen.
Du musst das jetzt auch mal ausprobieren.
Und ich habe ChatGPT damals eine ganz...
Haben wir sogar, glaube ich, im Stream gemacht.
Eine ganz simple Aufgabe gestellt.
Und zwar, ich wollte in .NET...
Ich wollte die Sharp-Source-Code haben.
Von ChatGPT.
Was einen Download-Progress-Balken anzeigt.
Datei runterladen, also Command-Line.
Command-Line.
Progress-Balken.
Beim Download von der Datei.
Das ist, wenn man weiß, wie man es macht, ist es nicht...
Es ist easy.
Ich müsste kurz überlegen und gucken.
Und in 20 Minuten ist das fertig.
So.
Und ChatGPT hat angefangen mit...
Das hat dann so Dinger geschrieben wie...
httpclient.onProgress.
Das Ding ist nur...
httpclient hat kein OnProgress-Event.
Das gibt es einfach nicht.
Das hat sich ChatGPT einfach ausgedacht, dass es das gibt.
So.
Und dann habe ich ChatGPT gesagt...
Ey, ChatGPT.
Die Methode gibt es nicht.
Und dann hat ChatGPT gesagt...
Ach, sorry.
Hier ein neues...
Hier ein neu generiertes Beispiel.
Und da kam eine Windows-Forms-Anwendung raus.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Einfach random eine Windows-Forms-Anwendung.
Da habe ich gesagt...
Okay, ChatGPT.
Ich lasse es bleiben.
Zisch ab.
Und seitdem habe ich das für solche Sachen gar nicht erst wieder angefasst.
Einfach für so Syntax-Überprüfungen.
Wobei, was ja keine richtige Syntax-Überprüfung ist.
Dafür ist das echt...
Gerade für YAML-Dateien ist ChatGPT gut.
Und insbesondere für Kubernetes-Files.
Wofür...
Also, wenn ihr Kubernetes-YAML-Files bekommt,
beispielsweise irgendeinen Helm-Chat generiert,
und das macht nicht genau das Richtige.
Das generiert ja immer relativ viel Output.
Da könnt ihr das dann reinpacen und sagen...
Ey, sag mir mal...
Tja, keine Ahnung.
Warum ist das Startup-Command falsch?
Und dann sagt er...
Ah ja, hier, klar.
Startup-Command...
Oder Command...
Oder Args?
Nee, Command heißt es, glaube ich.
Ist falsch eingerückt.
Ja, das haben schon viele gesagt.
Ich würde jetzt noch mal die gleichen Aufgaben mit ChatGPT 4 probieren.
Aber das fand ich so unterirdisch schlecht,
dass ich mir das noch keinen Bock hatte.
Was findest du besser?
VisualBox oder Hyper...
Du meinst VirtualBox, oder?
Möchte ein bisschen in PowerShell verbessern, weiß aber nicht welche...
Hä?
Weißt du was?
Das Chat-Comment hier...
Ich weiß, dass du es nicht bist.
Das klingt AI-generated gerade ein bisschen,
weil das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Warum brauchst du...
Warum brauchst du eine VM um PowerShell auszuprobieren?
Ich meine, du kannst das natürlich machen, ja?
Also, fangen wir mal erstens an.
Was findest du besser?
VirtualBox oder Hyper?
Wie keines von beiden?
VMware Workstation.
Guck hier.
Beste.
VMware Workstation.
Ja?
Also Hyper-V schon mal gar nicht für Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Und VirtualBox...
Ja, kann man ausprobieren, wenn man Probleme mit VMware Workstation hat.
Aber nehmen, VMware Workstation.
Ist sogar ab heute kostenlos, habe ich gehört.
So, wie du dich am besten mit PowerShell verbesserst...
Ja, er ist wahrscheinlich PowerShell benutzt.
Das ist ja auch das, was ich vielen Leuten mit Linux immer rate.
So, hier, wie kann ich das machen und hier jenes und wie kann ich da Know-How aufbauen?
Das Beste ist tatsächlich Linux tagtäglich benutzen.
Einfach benutzen erstmal, ja?
Gar nicht hier irgendwie krasse Scripting-Hackermans-Gedöns machen wollen,
sondern einfach benutzen.
Durch das tägliche Benutzen und sich mit den ein oder anderen Problemen auseinandersetzen,
die man da so hat, ja?
So, was weiß ich, wo liegen meine Config-Files?
Wie klone ich auf der Kommandozeile irgendeinen Git-Repo?
Ja, wie bediene ich meinen Terminal?
Wie bediene ich meine Shell?
Wie richte ich irgendwelche Sachen ein?
Da musst du dich zwangsläufig mal früher oder später mit allen essentiellen Parts
deines Betriebssystems auseinandersetzen, ja?
Ja, wie...
Wie...
Ups, Entschuldigung.
Okay, Festplatte ist irgendwie voll.
Wie ist die Verzeichnisstruktur aufgebaut?
Wo finde ich irgendwie meine Devices, wenn ich da was machen will?
Wie formatiere ich einen USB-Stick und sowas?
Da kommst du, wenn du das einfach tagtäglich benutzt,
früher oder später mal so gut wie an allen Stationen vorbei
und hast am Ende enorm viel gelernt.
Also am besten ist echt tägliches, tägliches Benutzen.
Und ehrlich gesagt,
ich vermute, dass das mit PowerShell ähnlich ist.
Ich hätte keinen Bock, tagtäglich PowerShell unter Windows zu benutzen.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das auch die beste Variante, ja.
Wobei, man muss ja sagen, mittlerweile, guck mal hier,
mittlerweile gibt es PowerShell auch für Linux.
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt unschlüssig, wann und weshalb und warum
und wieso ich das benutzen sollte.
Aber es geht auf jeden Fall, wenn man...
wenn man Hardcore-Windows-PowerShell-Fan ist.
Es gibt doch Edge für Linux, ja?
Mal gucken, ob es das auch für Arch-Linux gibt.
Warum hat denn das?
Alter, das müssen ja echt Leute verwenden.
Guckt mal, das hat 116 Upvotes, das Package.
Warum hat denn das so viel?
Und, und, und...
But why?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, was willst du?
Was willst du machen?
Wo soll ich anfangen, wenn ich Ansible lernen möchte?
Unter Linux auf jeden Fall solltest du anfangen.
Ich glaube, man kann Ansible auch ganz gut unter Windows verwenden,
da fehlt mir aber die Erfahrung.
Da müssen wir mal den Chat fragen.
Chat, wie gut ist der Ansible Support unter Windows?
Ich habe früher zwar nie was mit Ansible unter Windows gemacht,
aber ich habe mal kurzzeitig Puppet unter Windows verwendet.
Falls das noch jemand kennt.
Und das war enormst Pains-Champ.
Wirklich ultra Pains-Champ.
Ich finde den Chat immer geil, wenn der Chat so random Dinge einstreut.
NixOS größer Ansible.
Wenn es gerade darum geht, ob Ansible Windows abfackeln kann oder nicht.
Passt richtig gut dabei.
Okay, geht so.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe es mit Chat-GPT-4 noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ja.
Aber wie gesagt, ich bin kein großer Virtual-Box-Fan.
Schau, hast du Terra-Crunt gemacht?
Nee.
Raw Terraform, beste.
Schon das Repo gesehen, das du gepostet hast?
Nee.
Ich sehe auch kein gepostetes Repo.
Muss nochmal posten.
Was ist das für eine Shell, hat irgendjemand gefragt.
Wo ist das?
Hier, ist das ZSH?
Ja, das ist ZSH.
Das ist hier Echo Shell.
Das ist ZSH.
Allerdings, ich verwende kein Plugin-Framework mit Plugin-Manager und 50.000 Sachen in meiner Shell.
Meine Shell ist tatsächlich relativ raw.
Ich habe natürlich einige Sachen drin, die das Leben einfacher machen.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich nichts aktiviert.
Hier ist mal meine...
Ich habe...
Magic Zeug aktiviert.
Ich sollte...
Wisst ihr?
Ich müsste echt mal...
Das könnten wir eigentlich mal in einem gesonderten Stream machen, ja?
Ich könnte mal meine Shell ordentlich konfigurieren und das hier kommentieren, dass ich weiß, was was ist.
Ich hatte...
Diese...
Meine ZSH-Config ist...
Try and Error entstanden.
Ich hatte irgendein Problem, was mich genervt hat und habe gegoogelt, was für eine Option ich setzen muss und habe sie gesetzt.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf, was das da macht.
Push D Ignore Dubs.
Keine Ahnung.
Push D Silent.
Auto Push D.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich müsste das mal kommentieren, dass ich wüsste, was...
Ich glaube, Auto Push D ist folgendes.
Wenn ich in ein Verzeichnis drinne war und wechsle jetzt das Verzeichnis, dann kann ich mit 1, 2, 3 die letzten Verzeichnisse, in denen ich drinne war, durchschalten.
Ich glaube, das...
Ich glaube, das ist das.
So.
Und dann...
Ja.
Keine Ahnung, was das...
Was das alles macht.
Vor allem...
ZStyle.
Kompletition.
Matcherlist.
M...
Regex.
Zeug.
Keine Ahnung.
Und natürlich...
Und natürlich das hier.
Ganz klar.
If Test.
Minus T Null.
Und...
Dollar Minus.
Gleich...
Wild...
Okay, ernst gemeinte Frage.
Chat, was macht das?
Vielleicht krieg ich raus, wofür das ist, wenn ich das hier suche.
Enable x on, x off.
Aaaaaaah.
Ich weiß, was das ist.
Das ist Control-S.
Abschalten.
Glaub ich.
Ich glaub, das ist Control-S abschalten.
Control-S auf.
Control-S freest normalerweise deine Shell.
Control-S freest normalerweise deine Shell für irgendwelche prähistorischen Reasons.
Und das schalte das ab.
Was das hier macht, habe ich allerdings keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, T...
Was war...
Ach ne, da muss ich glaube ich hier sogar gucken.
Ja, fuck man.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe kein Schimmer, was das macht.
Oder...
Ich weiß nicht.
Ne, was ist das? Info oder so?
Ach, ey, keine Ahnung mehr, wie man sich diesen Build-In-Shit überhaupt anzeigen lässt.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was das hier macht.
Das testet...
Whatever auf Null?
Chat, wer mir das erklären kann, kriegt einen Gifts-Sub.
Wir machen jetzt...
Erklärt dem Max...
Seine eigene Shell-Config.
Please.
Also ich weiß, was das hier macht.
Es schaltet...
Ähm...
Control-S ab.
Relativ, relativ sicher, ja.
In Chat-GPT.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee, Chat.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Wir fragen Chat-GPT.
Und zwar DuckDuckGo.
AI-Chat.
Was macht das hier in meiner ZSH-RC?
Machen wir mal die Zeilennummern weg.
Sind wir mal so nett.
Äh, dieser Code...
Überprüft, ob...
Ob das aktuelle Terminal ein interaktives Terminal ist.
Wenn dies der Fall ist...
Ja, okay, aber...
Aber wie macht es das?
Einzelheiten erklären.
Okay, jetzt...
High IQ.
Das ist eine Bedingung, die überprüft, ob das aktuelle Terminal ein interaktives Terminal ist.
Aha.
Ah ja.
Minus T überprüft, ob der Dateideskript durch Starter Input mit einem Terminal verbunden ist.
Okay.
Das heißt...
Wenn ich ZSH in irgendeinem Skript ausführe, oder irgendwie Sub-Shell-mäßig, oder was auch immer,
dann wird das nicht ausgeführt.
Das ist eigentlich sehr sinnig, aber...
So, und Minus Dings I überprüft, ob das Shell-Flag I in der Umgebungsvariable enthalten ist,
was zeigt, dass die Shell im interaktiven Modus läuft.
Alles klar.
Das checkt, ob es eine interaktive Shell ist.
Nice.
Für sowas ist das praktisch.
Ja, so.
Dann habe ich noch Dinger...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, das brauche ich, dass ich mit 1, 2, 3, 1 bis 9 Verzeichnisse durchspringen kann.
Dann setze ich meine History auf...
Ich weiß, mittlerweile geht das auch besser.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile gibt es History Size Unlimited auch schon.
Ich glaube, man muss das mittlerweile gar nicht mehr setzen auf so einen hohen Wert.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile gibt es irgendeine Option für Unlimited.
So.
Das hier sind irgendwelche Keybindings.
Für Spezialtasten, wie zum Beispiel POS 1 und Ende, die manchmal rumbuggen.
Nicht in Bash, aber in ZSH.
Ja, das ist hier der Home-Datei-Ende-Knopf.
Das Ganze mit Doppel-Escape ist drin, damit es, glaube ich, auch potenziell in einem T-Mux funktioniert.
Dann...
Dann das Alt...
...plus Raute funktioniert.
Okay.
Das Alt plus Raute funktioniert zum Auskommentieren von Zeilen.
Das ist sehr nice, sehr praktisch.
Ich erwische mich immer wieder dabei, dass ich so mache.
Ja.
Aber eigentlich ist Alt plus Raute viel nicer.
Also, das ist zum Beispiel praktisch, wenn ihr irgendwas tippt.
Also, ich will jetzt hier irgendwas kreppen, plupp, keckel, Dings.
Und jetzt denkt ihr euch so...
Äh, Moment mal.
Was, was musste ich jetzt nochmal kurz nach?
Was, was musste ich machen?
Ah, das habe ich im vorletzten Command doch getippt.
Dann macht ihr einfach so.
Guckt hoch, was ihr tippen wollt.
Und dann macht ihr weiter.
Wie gesagt, das geht alles auf 500 verschiedene Varianten.
Ja, man kann auch das Ding in einem Editor aufmachen, die komplette Zeile.
Das mache ich, das mache ich so gut wie nie.
Man kann auch quasi das hier in einem WIM schalten.
Ja.
Starten lassen und dann besonders lange Zeilen editieren und so.
So, History Search.
Vorwärts und rückwärts.
Wort vor und zurück.
Ja, das brauche ich auch oft.
Also, Wort vor und zurück ist hier, dass ich das machen kann.
Guckt.
Hä, jetzt geht es auf einmal.
Eben was broken.
Keine Ahnung.
Guckt, dass es wortweise vor und zurück springt.
Ah ja, und wer sich jetzt fragt, wie zum Teufel soll ich denn überhaupt diese Escape-Sequenzen hier rauskriegen?
Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach.
Ihr macht einfach Cat auf und tippt mal was ein.
Ja, macht mal hier zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich habe jetzt Alt gedrückt und Pfeiltaste links und da seht ihr, ach guckt mal, Backward Word.
Da wisst ihr, was ihr hier eintragen müsst.
Dann habe ich irgendwas zum Ausrechnen von Prozessspeicher und Zeug.
Das brauche ich aber gar nicht mehr.
So, Aliasse für alle möglichen Config-Files.
Wetter, ganz wichtig.
Wetter in Hanau.
Wetter ist sehr nice.
Kann man jetzt, mit Image-Support, Leute, hat das mittlerweile, mit Image-Support.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das, ist das gerade down?
Ist Wetter in gerade down?
Oder schon, schon länger?
Oder, oh, das ist ja doof.
Ja, das ist down.
Scheint broken zu sein.
Warst du letztes Jahr auf der Bundeskanzlei in Fulda?
Nee.
Du wusstest, du hast meine Schirme am Hauptmann aufgehört.
Die Chancen sind, auch wenn man da ist, doch sehr gering, aber möglich ist es, ja.
Möglich ist es.
So, Wetter.
Image-Flaschen.
History, dass das immer die komplette History ausgibt.
Dass LS standardmäßig farbig ist.
Zwei Sachen, weil ich es mir nicht merken kann.
Ohne Scheiß, das Beste, was ich, oder eines.
Alter.
Why?
What the fuck?
Nutze es aktiv, ja, aber nicht hier auf meinem Streaming-Rechner.
Privat nutze ich das aktiv.
Legit, eines der besten Sachen, die ich je in meine Bash-RC eingefügt habe.
Irgendjemand von unseren High-IQ-Leuten oder Chat-GPT im Chat, der weiß, was das macht.
Das ist super High, also nicht super High-IQ, aber mega praktisch.
Und zwar, ihr könnt es ruhig hören.
reinschreiben, das dauert ein bisschen zu erklären.
Also, wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel
häkel,
ah, das gibt's schon.
0w123, okay, ja.
Ja, so.
Wenn ich jetzt hier ein paar Sachen anlege,
machen wir irgendwie
mal tausend
Dateien jetzt hier angelegt.
So, es kommt ja total oft
vor, dass Leute
sowas hier machen.
Ja, sagen wir mal,
rm-rf
0w123.
Dann fragt er dich,
ja, wollen sie das
Recursive
entfernen? Dann musst du sagen, ja.
Und das kommt daher,
weil
das minus i
da dran steht. So.
Und jetzt kommt's.
Ich
lege das Ding nochmal an.
Wenn ich das jetzt mal von Hand
mache, ja, bin
...
rm-rf
und jetzt machen wir mal, ich hab's irgendwie
irgendwann schon mal gezeigt, ja, und jetzt machen
wir mal minus i
0w123.
Äh, ich hab's falsch rum
gemacht, glaub ich.
Oder ist das, oder ist das nicht immer so?
Ja, genau. Jetzt wirst du nämlich
nicht gefragt, obwohl das minus i da
steht. Guck mal. Das heißt,
was zuerst
steht, zählt zuerst.
Also selbst, wenn ich Interactive
angebe und danach
minus Force rm,
dann überschreibt das
minus i.
Das ist ganz weird. Und hiermit
stelle ich sicher, dass egal, was ich
eintippe bei rm-rf,
das minus Interactive immer am Ende
steht. Und
es gibt auch noch einen Unterschied
zwischen den, ja,
es gibt auch noch einen Unterschied zwischen klein i
und großem i.
Großem i ist,
nee, ich glaub, das ist Absicht.
Das ist Absicht.
Das steht hier auch irgendwo,
dass das, das überschreibt.
Ja, ähm, so.
Und der Unterschied zwischen kleinem i und
großem i ist,
bei kleinem i fragt er dich vor jeder Datei,
ob du die entfernen willst, immer.
Und bei groß i
fragt er dich nur,
wenn es mehr als drei
Dateien sind. Also, nur wenn
du wirklich, du brauchst das
viel kaputt zu machen. So, und
ja, also wenn ich jetzt,
jetzt,
hier sind
hier jetzt nochmal Touch, hier sind jetzt
tausende Dateien drin, ne? Und wenn ich
jetzt sag, hier rm-rf Sternchen,
dann fragt er mich,
ja, und dann, bäm.
Weil es sind, es sind ja mehr,
es sind ja mehr als, es sind ja mehr
als drei. Und wenn man nicht mehr
genervt werden möchte, weil das Ding auch
zig Unterverzeichnisse hat und sonst was,
dann muss man einfach yes nach
rm-rf pipen.
Dann geht das auch.
So, so mach ich das,
dass ich nicht aus Versehen was lösche
und dass ich nicht solche
behelfsmäßige Dinger brauch wie
ein Papierkorb. Es gibt ja ein paar
Kommandozeilen-Tools unter Linux,
die aliassen dann rm
auf
dass es nicht mehr rm ist
und verschieben die Dateien aber
eigentlich nur in so einen Papierkorb.
Und seitdem ich das hab,
hab ich nie wieder irgendwas aus Versehen gelöscht,
nie wieder das Falsche gelöscht
und auch schon gar nicht irgendwie
zu viel gelöscht, weil wenn es zu viel ist,
dann musst du das noch in yes davor pipen
und das passiert nicht aus Versehen.
Kann man so Functions auch in Bash,
ja, ja, ja, das geht eins zu eins in Bash auch so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die allereleganteste
Variante ist, das so zu machen,
aber das funktioniert bei mir ganz gut.
So, und der Rest ist glaube ich nicht mehr
so interessant irgendwie.
Wobei ImageCat ist auch noch nice,
weil meine Shell kann ja Bilder,
was ja
das allerwichtigste Feature überhaupt ist.
Ganz wichtig.
So, und ansonsten
whatever.
Keine Ahnung.
Jetzt übrigens alles auf GitHub ist,
kann man sich angucken.
Ich müsste das wirklich mal kommentieren,
dass ich selbst noch verstehen würde,
was da eigentlich passiert.
Also, oh my zisch,
mag ich gar nicht.
Ich hab mir das selbst customised
und ich mein,
man sieht ja hier,
ein paar zusätzliche Sachen
hab ich noch drinne.
Ja,
zum Beispiel Auto-Suggestions
und Syntax-Highlighting.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Ihr seht ja, wenn ich hier irgendwie was schreibe,
so hier, ne, also while true echo 1, 2, 3,
dann wird das Syntax-Highlighted.
Das kommt von dem Syntax-Highlight-Plugin.
Das finde ich ganz praktisch,
gerade wenn so ein paar 1-Teile-Dinger
ganz mal schnell auf der Shell-Zusammenskript,
das finde ich sehr praktisch.
Und dann habe ich noch Auto-Completion.
Auto-Completion,
ist das, was ihr jetzt hier hinten seht.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt hier sage LSLA
und dann sagt der hier,
du hast das letzte Mal dieses Kommando verwendet,
willst du nicht jetzt wieder das Gleiche hinten dran machen?
Dann kann ich sagen, okay,
ja, ich accepte die Auto-Completion
und drücke eine Taste
und dann macht das Gleiche nochmal.
Das sind aber eigentlich so die einzigen zwei Dinger,
die ich da an Plugins noch hab.
Ja, aber genug zu meiner Shell, ja.
Doc, was, Dokumenso,
kenne ich nicht.
Oh, das klingt nach Zertifikats-Signing-Gedöns.
Kenne ich nicht.
Nee, sagt mir nix.
Virtual Box ist Paints,
vor allem mit Windows.
Das macht aber KVM, oder?
Nutzt das nicht KVM unter der Haube?
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Windows Terminal ist ja auch Schrott ohne Ende.
Hyper Schrott, Alter.
So, machen wir das hier mal wieder zu.
Ich weiß nicht so wirklich,
wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin.
Aber ein bisschen Sidetracking,
muss sein.
Ich bin heute am Hauptbahnhof in Frankfurt vorbeigelaufen, ja.
Ist ja, ist ja eigentlich nix Besonderes.
Ich bin's ja mittlerweile gewöhnt, aber
ich hatte heute ein bisschen mehr Zeit.
Ich bin zur vollen Stunde rausgelaufen und
dementsprechend hatte ich quasi fünf Minuten länger Zeit als sonst.
Bin ich auch ein bisschen langsamer gelaufen und
Leute, was da mittlerweile für Leute rumstehen, Alter.
Ich mein, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof war schon immer
war schon immer zwischen
MonKS und KeckWaite, was da rumstand.
Also schon immer zwischen
fürchten und
und ja,
wundern und warten, dass irgendwas passiert, so.
Also, aber
mittlerweile, ey,
trau ich, wo die
kommen die alle her, die Leute, die da im Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof stehen?
Ist das so Leute, die es überhaupt gibt?
Also, ich bin's ja mittlerweile gewohnt, was, was ganz merkwürdig ist,
auf dem Weg zum Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, das ist so ein neues Ding, ich weiß nicht so genau, woran das liegt,
hängen jetzt total viele Leute rum,
die einen immer angucken und grüßen, die sagen immer, hallo, hallo oder oder
alles klar, alles klar oder sowas. Ich weiß nicht, ob die mit
dir ins Gespräch kommen wollen, um dir irgendwelche Drogen zu verkaufen.
Oder wenn du stehen bleibst, raubt dich einer von hinten aus oder so.
Aber dieses an, dieses, dieses so von der Seite angesprochen werden, so, so, so, das ist so ganz merkwürdig, das gab's früher die ganze Zeit nicht.
Wobei man auch sagen muss, ich finde, das Klientel am Frankfurter Haupt, was man das, falls man das so nennen kann,
das Klientel am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof hat sich ein bisschen gewandelt.
Es gibt immer noch
gefühlt sehr viele Drogenabhängige und Leute, die da irgendwie in der Ecke rumgammeln und so.
Aber was so die letzten Jahre über zugenommen hat, ist, wie beschreibe ich denn die Leute am besten?
Also ich kenne die ja nicht, ich kann die ja nur optisch, optisch beschreiben.
Kennt ihr dieses Meme mit dem einen Film mit Tom Hanks, wo er mit dem Terroristen auf dem Schiff ist und der, der, der, der, Moment, Moment.
Da gibt's doch dieses eine Bild mit diesem
Tom Hanks und diesem Look-at-me-Typ.
Look-at-me.
Ja.
Moment, Copy-Image-Address.
What the fuck?
Warum kann ich nicht, warum kopiert das nicht die Image-Address?
Wahnsinn.
So.
So sehen gefühlt 90% der Leute am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof mittlerweile aus und die gucken dich genauso an wie der Typ.
Und, also, das hat sich schon ein bisschen gewandelt die letzten Jahre.
Also, auf dem Weg zum Hauptbahnhof, das hat sich die letzten Jahre über schon gewandelt, weg von einfach nur, ja, Gehirn kaputt in der Ecke liegend zu solchen Leuten.
Aber die sehen, die sehen genauso aus, wie der Typ auf dem Bild Richtung Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Ja, das wäre mir auch aufgefallen, als ich aber ein bisschen langsamer langgelaufen bin.
Das hat sich, hat sich gewandelt.
Das hat sich gewandelt, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, dafür musst du dir, dafür, eine Sache ist tatsächlich besser geworden am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Es liegen weniger Spritzen rum.
Es könnte jetzt auch liegen, dass die vielleicht mehr aufräumen oder so, weiß ich.
Aber insgesamt liegen weniger Spritzen und solche, solche Geschichten rum.
Also, gerade früher, ich weiß noch, wo ich klein war, war ich öfters mit meinem Vater am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Da sind wir ja immer, ich bin früher, als ich klein war, bin ich mega gerne U-Bahn gefahren.
Und da musste mein Vater manchmal mit mir da im Kreis mit der U-Bahn fahren und so.
Da war, da war, da war richtig so Spritzen und Nadeln überall und sowas.
War, war später immer noch, ja, hatte man immer noch, musste man ein bisschen aufpassen.
Aber da ist, da, da siehst du jetzt kaum noch was, muss man.
Das, das ist tatsächlich besser geworden am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Dortmund Haupt, Dortmund Hauptbahnhof war ich noch nie.
Also, der letzte Bahnhof, wo mir aufgefallen ist, wo ich auch erst mich direkt an Frankfurt erinnert,
gefühlt habe, ist Berlin.
Berlin Hauptbahnhof.
Da, da habe ich mich überhaupt nicht zurechtgefunden.
Da bin ich rausgegangen und das Erste, was passiert ist, irgendein, ja, keine Ahnung, ich sage jetzt mal Penner,
sah zumindest so aus, hat mir, ich habe, ich habe, ich habe die Tür aufgemacht.
Da kam mir der Typ entgegen, die, die eiern ja immer so ein bisschen rum und hustet mir voll ins Gesicht.
Da habe ich gesagt, ey, ist ja wieder heim, Alter, ist wieder heim.
Aber ansonsten ist es natürlich schon etwas netter.
Berlin am Hauptbahnhof.
Zumindest an der einen Seite, wo ich raus bin, weil da ist ziemlich viel offene, offene Sicht und ein bisschen,
bisschen Grün, Grünfläche und wenn man von da weiterläuft, kommt man auch am Reichstag vorbei und Brandenburger Tor.
Also im Prinzip alles, was man in Berlin sehen will, kann man sich vom Hauptbahnhof angucken innerhalb von 20 Minuten und dann fährt man wieder weg.
Dann ist man, dann ist gut, genug Kulturprogramm.
Ja, wie gesagt, es ist in den letzten Jahren ist das mit Nadeln und solchen
Drogengeschichten am Hauptbahnhof viel besser geworden.
Dafür hast du jetzt so Typen, wie ich dir gerade gezeigt habe, da in Massen stehen.
Nicht im Hauptbahnhof und im Hauptbahnhof siehst du eh so gut wie nichts, seitdem es da sehr viel Polizeipräsenz und Bahn Security Präsenz gibt.
Also im Hauptbahnhof selber ist so gut wie gar nichts.
Du hast ein paar fertige Leute rumirren oftmals, aber das war's ja.
Manchmal ganz selten hast du, wenn du sehr früh da bist, irgendwie einen Typ in einem
kaputten Schaufenster liegen oder sowas.
Aber es ist kaum was ans Trinken erinnern.
Exzellent.
Also im Hauptbahnhof selbst, das ist ja auch eines der Lieblingsfragen auf Reddit irgendwie.
Ist es sicher am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof?
Ja, es ist sicher, wenn man da aussteigen, umsteigen muss, innen drin ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Draußen ist es kein brasilianischer Slum oder so.
Das ist schon okay.
Aber sonderlich angenehm ist es dort trotzdem nicht.
Und wenn man mal in die Seitenstraße geht vom Hauptbahnhof.
Da ist halt.
Da ist halt mehr Elend als gefährlich, so richtig.
Also die ganzen fertigen Leute, die auf der Straße da irgendwie rumliegen, kurz vorm Verrecken.
Naja, also schön ist es wirklich nicht, Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel.
Kann man echt nicht sagen.
Es gibt ja sogar Führungen durch das Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel.
Weiß echt nicht, was man sich da groß angucken will.
Die, die, die, die, wie heißt das?
Nicht Drogenausgabestation, sondern.
Also diese.
Ersatzausgabe, Ersatz Drogenausgabestation oder was, wenn man sich da angucken bei der Führung durchs Bahnhofsviertel.
Wie viele Tage derzeit im Homeoffice?
Also ich arbeite vier Tage die Woche, davon drei Tage Homeoffice, ein Tag vor Ort.
Im Durchschnitt kommt sicherlich irgendwann auch mal vor, weil ich zwei Tage da bin und es kommt sicherlich auch mal vor, dass ich alle Tage daheim bin.
Aber im Durchschnitt ist es so vier Tage arbeiten, davon drei Tage Homeoffice, ein Tag vor Ort.
Heute war ich übrigens vor Ort.
Hätte das gedacht, nachdem ich über die Bahn flamen musste.
Die haben jetzt ein neues geiles Feature in der Bahn App.
Man sieht alte Verbindungen nicht mehr richtig.
Also alte Verbindungen sind Verbindungen, von denen die Bahn denkt, dass sie schon angekommen sind.
Schwinden einfach.
Dass man nicht mal nachgucken kann, dass er Zugverspätung hatte.
Ich wollte heute Morgen screenshotten.
Dass sie es geschafft haben, auf eine 3 Minuten Verbindung über 11 Minuten Verspätung zu bekommen.
Also die Verbindung hat quasi drei bis vierfach so lange gedauert.
Und dann habe ich den Zug nicht erwischt, musste einen anderen Zug fahren.
Also im Regionalexpress am Hauptbahnhof, was mir da öfters auffällt, also bekifft der Typ, keine Ahnung.
Aber was mir da öfters auffällt, sind die Typen, die kennt ihr vielleicht auch, die am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof einsteigen und durch den Zug laufen.
Früher sind die rumgelaufen.
Ja, kennt ihr ja noch so von früher, so nach dem Motto, ah, ob man mal einen Euro hat und sowas.
Heute ist das, heute ist das, ähm, trickreicher.
Heute steigen die in Zug ein und sagen, oh, sie müssen dringend nach Fulda, ihre Tochter ist krank, ob man ihr Geld für ein Ticket hat und sowas.
Und ich habe schon gesehen, dass Leute denen Geld gegeben haben.
Und wenigstens so zu tun und den Schein zu wahren, dass das stimmt, was die Leute erzählen.
Aber nein.
Der ist quasi einfach zum nächsten Platz gegangen, hat die gleiche Story wiedererzählt.
Der ist nicht etwa ein Abteil weiter, dass der Typ, der ihm Geld gegeben hat, wenigstens nicht checkt, dass er ihm Scheiße erzählt hat.
Nee, der ist einfach direkt zum nächsten gegangen und hat gesagt, meine Tochter ist im Krankenhaus in Fulda, ich bin total fertig, ich muss dahin, ich habe kein Geld.
Ja, das ist das High-Performer-Grindset-Mindset.
Das lernt man bestimmt in der Gruppe, ja.
Leute belästigen im Zug in Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Hast du Empfehlungen fürs Essen gehen, wenn ich mal wieder länger umstehe?
Ich habe tatsächlich was, was ich sehr nice finde in Frankfurt, habe ich letztens erst entdeckt.
Also entdeckt, mir hat das einer empfohlen, da war ich da, fand ich gut.
Wenn man auf sowas steht hier, Frankfurt, Korean, Fried Chicken und zwar...
Cheeking, Cheeking City.
Richtig nice.
Ja, wer das mit Pommes...
Pommes frites futtert, dem ist eh nicht zu helfen, ja.
Mega nice.
Leider sieht man das ja alles immer nur mit Pommes frites.
So hier, ja, so sieht das aus.
Richtig nice.
Also, das ist nicht die...
Also, wenn ihr euch das Normale bestellt, ist die Portion größer.
Das hier ist wahrscheinlich Mittagsmenü mit was zu trinken noch dabei.
Schmeckt richtig nice.
Warum es da zwei Stück Melone gibt, verstehe ich allerdings auch nicht.
Ja, aber das ist nice.
Das ist auch um die Ecke vom Hauptbahnhof.
Und Mittagsmenü, Mittagsmenü kostet nur 12 Euro.
Vor ein paar Jahren wäre das übelst teuer gewesen, aber mittlerweile ist 12 Euro echt ganz okay.
Also, das kann ich empfehlen, das schmeckt gut.
Korean Fried Chicken.
Und die sind sehr schnell.
Du setzt dich rein, bestellst, fünf Minuten später hast du dein Essen.
Oder zehn Minuten später.
Also, die sind wirklich sehr zackig.
Fünf bis zehn Minuten.
Blubb.
Und die Hähnchen haben keine Knochen drin.
Also, du kannst einfach wegspachteln.
Servus, was hältst du von Umschulung?
Ich habe nie eine Umschulung gemacht.
Ich persönlich finde die Möglichkeit nicht verkehrt.
Man muss aber sagen, dass gerade die Arbeitsamtsschulungen, habe ich teilweise den Eindruck,
die versuchen alles und jeden auf, ja, alles und jedes umzuschulen.
Und das ist einfach so.
Du kannst nicht jeden.
Der keinen Job findet, zum Fachinformatiker umschulen.
Für manche Leute ist das einfach nichts.
Und das soll jetzt nicht heißen, ey, das ist besser oder so.
Für mich wären viele andere Berufe auch nichts.
Ja, aber du kannst nicht, keine Ahnung, Werner, der mit Technik gar nichts zu tun hat,
und sein ganzes Leben im Bergwerk gearbeitet hat, um jetzt mal übertrieben was zu sagen,
den kannst du nicht zum Physio umschulen.
Kannst du schon, wenn er sich dafür interessiert und auch da Privatinteresse und allem hat.
Aber wenn er es nicht macht.
Dann hat er es ja auch keinen Sinn.
Mach mal einen Umschulpunkt.
Warum, dass ich dann endlich was mit Holz arbeiten kann oder wie?
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, genau sowas meine ich.
Genau sowas meine ich, ja.
Ja.
Leute, die über Schreibmaschinen noch nicht rausgekommen sind und wohlgemerkt auch keinerlei Interesse daran haben,
die werden dann, äh,
mit dem Physio umgeschult, ja, das ist, das ist schon ein bisschen
Painschamp.
Ja gut, das habe ich ja auch schon öfters erzählt, das war bei mir ja nicht anders.
Chat, gut, dass ihr, es hat alles seine Vorteile.
Überlegt euch mal, die, die Sekretärin hat sich irgendwie Ransomware eingefangen und
der zentrale Fileshell wird verschlüsselt, nix geht mehr.
Sein Onkel tippt immer noch Zeug auf der Schreibmaschine.
Manchmal ist analoge Technik vielleicht doch nicht so blöd, wie man denkt.
Und danach kann er das Ganze noch per Fax.
schicken.
Also komplette Firma noch handlungsfähig, nur weil noch eine Schreibmaschine und ein Faxgerät am Start ist.
Es ist eh der Witz, dass du in Deutschland auch für einige Sachen Faxgeräte zwingend brauchst.
Und gerade so Sachen wie, dass du das rechtlich verbindlich was zugestellt wurde und sowas,
ist ja viel klarer geregelt bei einem Fax, als beispielsweise bei einer E-Mail.
Auch im Jahr 2024 noch.
Oh.
Ja, heute ein bisschen Laberstream.
Bin ja froh, dass mich keiner,
bisher gefragt hat, Max, was machen wir heute?
Hätte ich nämlich sagen müssen, nix.
Ich schwätze ein bisschen vor mich hin.
Was Faxlizenzen erneuert?
Für Fax braucht man keine Lizenz.
Was ist älter, E-Mail oder Fax?
Das ist so eine Frage, wo jeder normalerweise darauf antworten würde, äh, Fax.
Aber, wenn man alles damit reinrechnet so, auch
vielleicht so die theoretischen Überlegungen für E-Mail und sowas,
keine Ahnung.
Aber ich, ich würde trotzdem sagen, Fax ist auf jeden Fall älter.
Es müsste allgemein ein bisschen weniger Bürokratie geben.
Das wäre schon nice.
Digitales oder analoges Fax?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas wie digitales Fax gibt.
Ich dachte, dass selbst digitales Fax eigentlich nur ein emuliertes analoges Fax ist.
Aber...
Fiat Champ hat keine Issues.
Die, die, das sind Skillissues der Anwender.
Wieso, gibt's da wieder was neues?
Ups.
Oh.
Ich müsste da echt mal dran und paar grundlegend Sachen umbauen, weil vieles ist gar nicht möglich.
Von dem, wie ich's gebaut hab.
Beispielsweise, wenn du zwei Autos hast bei einem unterschiedlichen Hersteller, geht das Ganze damit schon mal nicht.
Und da gibt es tatsächlich einige, sogar welche, die das schon auf GitHub geschrieben haben.
Ja, beispielsweise irgendwelche Amis, die einen Fiat haben, Fiat Elektroauto und dann auch irgendeinen Ram Truck oder sowas.
Und das kannst du aktuell mit dem Android nicht machen.
Ich müsste echt, boah, ich bin aber so faul gerade daran, weiterzubasteln.
Vielleicht wäre ich motivierter, wenn irgendjemand Bock drauf hätte, mitzumachen.
Aber ich bin sehr unzuverlässig.
Rewrite in Rust, damit das nicht mehr passiert.
Wie? Damit was nicht mehr passiert?
Dass ich mir eine blöde Anwendungsarchitektur ausdenke oder dass ich keinen Bock mehr habe?
Ich glaube, vor beidem kann mich Rust nur schwer beschützen.
Moin Max, wie läuft das Runners Game?
Ja, ich war vorhin gerade wieder eine Runde Rennen.
Allerdings heute hat mein Trainingsplan gesagt, 37 Minuten Base Run.
Also, lahm und nicht so lang.
Lahm, je nachdem, wie man es nennt, ja.
7 Minuten 5 pro Kilometer.
Das ist für den einen oder anderen relativ schnell.
Für manch anderen ist das abgrundtief langsam.
Kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an.
Schon mal einen Runners?
Ne, noch nie, noch nie.
Ich meine, nicht, dass mir nicht schon mal die Gelenke wehgetan hätten oder sowas, ja.
Aber das hatte ich, das hatte ich noch nie.
Was ich, was ich habe, wenn ich es übertreibe, ist, gerade wenn ich zu schnell gerannt bin und dann mal am nächsten Tag auch zu viel gemacht habe, ist, dass es eine Weile dauert, bis mir mein Schienbein nicht mehr wehtut.
Ja, ich meine, ich bin immer noch nicht der Leichteste.
Mir tut dann relativ schnell mal das Schienbein weh.
Aber das geht dann auch wieder weg.
Also, ne, hatte ich das Problem, hatte ich noch nicht.
Rust hilft bei allem.
Ja, Rust hilft bei allem dafür.
Er hilft bei allem.
Dafür, sich geil zu finden, weil man Rust verwendet.
Bundesnetzagentur sucht neuen Faxanbieter.
Okay, das war Januar letztes Jahr.
Kannst du mal das reviewen?
Bei der Air-Inform-Versicherung.
Ha, da kenne ich sogar jemanden, der da arbeitet.
Gucken, welches Team das ist.
Steht nicht da, oder?
Ist das da?
Keine Ahnung.
Also,
ja, da kenne ich einen, der dort arbeitet.
Ehemaliger Kollege.
Der ist da hingewechselt.
Muskeleak gab es schon öfters.
Ja, so muss das sein.
Ähm, okay.
Ich kann mal reingucken, ja.
Willst du dich da bewerben, oder wie?
Herr Darkseid?
Zeig mal, ja.
Wir sind versichert.
Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Was suchen sie denn überhaupt?
DevOps-Engineer?
MWD.
Nee, gucke ich.
E-Mail.
Also, wie gesagt, ich kenne einen, der dort arbeitet.
Ob das jetzt gleiche Zeug ist, keine Ahnung.
Die sind aber auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht.
Was ich gehört habe.
In ihrer Rolle unterstützen sie als Multiplikator.
MWD.
Du musst mit besonders vielen Leuten kompatibel sein, oder wie?
Multiplikator DevSecOps-Team.
DevSecWinBizOps.
Warum nicht nur mehr?
DevSecOps-Team ist dabei, ihren Reifegrad zu optimi...
Was?
Moment.
Nochmal, nochmal langsam.
Nochmal langsam.
Den Satz check ich nicht.
In ihrer Rolle unterstützen sie als Multiplikator DevSecOps-Teams dabei,
ihren Reifegrad zu optimieren,
die Prinzipien von DevSecOps zu verstehen,
Und diese in der Praxis umzusetzen.
Das hier leuchtet mir ja noch ein.
Die meinen mit Reifegrad eher sowas wie Kenntnisstand, oder?
Sowas wie Skill-Level.
Meinen die sowas wie Skill-Level damit?
Okay, das ist schon so kompliziert geschrieben,
dass ich mein Problem habe, die Stellenanzeige überhaupt zu checken.
Oder meinen die den Reifegrad ihrer Anwendung?
Whatever, keine Ahnung.
Das hätte man auch ein bisschen klarer schreiben können,
was jetzt eigentlich Sache ist.
Okay.
Konkret begleiten sie unterschiedliche Teams
im Rahmen der DevSecOps-Transformation von Mainframe.
Ah.
Nice Kobol-Hackermans.
Und Cloud-Entwicklern bis zur Infrastruktur-Bereitsteller.
Okay.
Um die Effizienz und Skalierbarkeit,
ah, ich hoffe aber diagonal, zu verbessern.
Übrigens, warum überhaupt Cloud?
Und Hyperscaler.
Leute, Hyperscaler.
Um die Effizienz und Skalierbarkeit zu verbessern,
tragen sie maßgeblich zur Automatisierung in den fachlichen Arzt...
What?
Okay.
Also, ich hatte schon Probleme bei dem ersten Satz.
Aber was soll denn das bedeuten?
Um die Effizienz und Skalierbarkeit...
Bis hierhin verstehe ich es ja noch.
Wer hier einen Punkt, ist okay.
Okay.
Sie maßgeblich zur Automatisierung in den fachlichen Arzt bei?
Ich kenne Warts.
Das ist so ein Zombiespiel.
Okay.
Wir fragen DuckDuckGo.
Was bedeutet das in einer Stellenanzeige?
Ach, die meinen damit sowas.
Agile Release Train.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ja, das würde allerdings zu DevOps-Engineer passen.
Hä?
Siehst du, nicht mal Chat-GPT weiß, was das damit eigentlich auf sich hat.
F-Ops 8.
Agile Release Train.
What the fuck?
Oh Mann.
Ah, the primary value delivery construct in SAFE.
Ah ja, klar.
Ah, okay.
Scalable Agile Framework, oder?
Heißt das?
SAFE.
Sorry, sorry.
Ah, Scaled Agile Framework.
Fast.
Ganzer Bullshit-Krempel da, man.
Äh, ähnlich wie der.
Können wir uns nicht einfach darauf beschränken, das zu machen, was eigentlich die Essenz von Agile ist?
Nämlich möglichst viel Manager-Kram von Entwicklern fernhalten.
Das ist die Essenz von Agile.
Entwickler ihren Job machen zu lassen und sich nicht den ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchem Management- und Orga-Kram auseinandersetzen zu müssen.
Und das denken wir uns nicht an.
Und das denken wir uns nicht an. Und das denken wir uns nicht an.
Das sagt einer der Mitgründer, Miterfinder dieser ganzen Sache.
Und nicht mit dem ganzen Zeug.
Da gibt's ja jeden Tag was Neues, Mann.
So ganz sinnlos sind Manager ja nicht, Chat.
Ja.
Ab und zu, gerade wenn sie was können, was natürlich nicht so einfach ist, aber, also was, wo es nicht so viele gibt, aber,
ist schon nicht verkehrt, ja, wenn du ein paar Leute hast, die gut organisieren können.
Und vor allem sind Manager dafür da, unter anderem Probleme aus dem Weg zu schaffen.
Und nicht...
sollten nicht mehr probleme schaffen als sie lösen sondern zumindest ist er eines
der hauptgedanken von agile dass entwickler eigenständig entwickeln
können ohne sich tagtäglich mit irgendwelchen
product owner manager und sonst was auseinanderzusetzen das ist der sinn von
als eines der hauptziele von agent so ok also hier wäre ich schon mal los
gewesen keine ahnung was sie da gewollt ich
weiß dass es wahrscheinlich agile release trains sind mit mit der einzige
punkt ist ich habe bis jetzt keine ahnung was eigentlich hl release trains
sind außer dass es das primary value delivering construct in safe ist da
wissen wir jetzt natürlich auch sofort bescheid ja ok aber dann ergibt es
zumindest sinn im kontext von einem der fox engineer weiterhin erarbeiten sie
best practice zu etablieren standards gemeinsam mit den teams oder
kommunikation
oder communities of practice warum muss man jedem kram irgendeinen bescheuerten
namen geben was sollen bitteschön communities of
practice sein alter das auch safe ja klar was sonst alter das ist ja grausam
das ist zum hyperskalieren dass das das mindset ja
communitys of practice kopf vielleicht auf der etwas und kürzer etwas
ungünstig habe kürzer anzeige ist raffels community to cops argon als groups
of people with the common interest in a specific technik business am moment ist
das das was bei anderen als tribes and fuck ich habe vergessen wie das heißt
Agile Tribes
Tribes and
ja
Dieses ganze Agile Zeug nimmt einfach echt überhand. Jeder denkt sich irgendeinen eigenen Scheiß aus, Mann.
Agile Scaling Tribes, Squads, Chapters and Guilds.
Alter, was ein Shit.
Ja, Squads, danach habe ich gesucht, Mann.
Wahnsinn, Alter.
Aber die sind richtig, richtig agil, hier auf jeden Fall.
Oh, Mann.
Beim Fördern des Bewusstseins für Sicherheitsaspekte und Compliance.
Gut, ja, wir sind hier bei einer Versicherung, da sind ein paar sowas immer, da sind die ganz, ganz scharf drauf.
In der Entwicklung und dem Betrieb von Anwendungen vertrauen wir auf ihr Engagement.
Okay, hey, wenigstens mal einen Satz, den ich verstehe.
Ne, habe ich nicht geguckt.
Das Durchführen von Workshops zu DevSecOps-Prozessen und Richtlinien sowie das Beraten und Unterstützen der Teams.
Ah, ja, und hoffentlich auch der Communities of Practice, ja.
Beim Umsetzen von DevSecOps-Praktiken runden die Aufgabenfeld ab.
Okay, das Problem bei dieser Stellenanzeige, was ich sehe, ist, nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie ein schlechter Laden wäre oder so.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Ähm, zumindest das, was ich gehört habe, ja, von meinem Kollegen, der dort arbeitet, der findet es da eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Also, die scheinen nicht schlecht zu sein.
Ich habe das Problem mit der Stellenanzeige.
Dass ich die Hälfte der Stellenanzeige, okay, sagen wir mal, ein Drittel der Stellenanzeige, schon mal gar nicht genau verstehe, was die eigentlich von mir wollen.
Würde mir die Serie gefallen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe bestimmt schon die einen oder anderen Ausschnitte gesehen.
Ich, ich, ich kenne das.
Ich kenne das.
Ich habe da schon ein paar Ausschnitte daraus gesehen.
Ist das, haben die da auch irgendeine, haben die da auch eine Inder im Team?
Wenn ja, dann kenne ich das.
Dann habe ich ein paar Ausschnitte davon schon mal gesehen.
Ja, ja.
Da habe ich schon ein paar Ausschnitte davon gesehen, ja.
Ja, das könnte mir durchaus gefallen.
Wobei ich, so, so Comedy-Sachen, ich, ich habe da das Problem, dass ich die, die meisten Sachen, die unter Comedy so laufen, nicht lustig finde.
Ich kann mir beispielsweise auch die Office nicht angucken.
Das, das ist einfach nur ultra cringe für mich und unangenehm.
Okay, was, wie geht, wie geht es denn hier weiter?
Ich weiß, dass das nicht auf cringe gemacht ist.
Wie gesagt, ich habe schon ein paar Ausschnitte gesehen.
Äh, IT-Crowd, oder wie das, wie ist das?
IT-Crowd?
Have you, have you tried to turn it off and on again?
Ja, genau.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was übelst gefeiert wird von vielen.
Ich konnte der Sache auch nichts abgewinnen.
Neues Firebase-Video.
Der Typ heißt Fireship.
Falls du den meinst.
Nicht Firebase.
Firebase ist das Cloud-Gedöns.
Fireship ist der YouTube-Channel.
So, also was suchen die denn sonst noch?
Profil.
Anforderung.
Okay.
Okay, die übliche, relevante Berufserfahrung im DevOps-Umfeld.
Ja, das wäre schon sinnvoll.
Fachwissen rund um DevSecOps-Praktiken, Technologien, CI, CD, Monitoring, Security, Orchestration, Automatisierung, sowie Kultur und Zusammenarbeit.
Das passt doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht zu dieser Aufzählung jetzt dabei.
Ja, das eine sind wirklich knallhart, sagen wir mal so, Technik-Sachen.
Und die Kultur, das hat irgendwas mit dem jeweiligen Unternehmen zu tun.
Das kannst du gar nicht wissen, bevor du da gewesen bist.
Ja.
Und dass man vielleicht auch mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeiten können sollte, so ein bisschen Soft-Skill-mäßig, wie man das so schön nennt.
Ja, gut, das verstehe ich.
Aber das passt in die Aufzählung hier nicht rein.
Erfahrung in der Zusammenarbeit mit Entwicklern und Betrieben.
Das finde ich tatsächlich cool, dass das drinne steht, ja.
Das ist als DevOps-Engineer tatsächlich recht wichtig.
Dass man mit beiden Seiten gut kann.
Problemlösungsorientierung, Selbstorganisation und Kommunikation sowie Präsentationsstärke gepaart mit der Fähigkeit, komplexe Konzepte...
Okay, ja, fließend Deutsch, idealerweise schon in Schrift.
Unser Angebot, Führereinsatz.
Jetzt kommt wieder ein Satz, ey.
Für die abwechslungsreiche Stelle sucht man ein offenes Kommunikationstalent mit Fokus auf Enabling.
Und Hickchen gesetzt quasi.
Dann ist es enabled.
Checkbox.
Ist sowohl technisch noch als auch kreative Lösung.
Die Stelle bietet zudem viel Gestaltung.
Sie erwartet ein starkes Team, das auf mittelfristig auch weiterhin zum Produktowner bzw. SAE Service...
Was ist ein SAE?
Side-Rel...
Ne.
Nein.
Niemand eine Ahnung?
Ne, das passt hier nicht wirklich drunter, unser Angebot für Ihren Einsatz, oder?
Passt thematisch nicht dazu.
Manchmal wäre es echt sinnvoll, wenn man die Sachen ausschreibt, oder?
Meine Senior... Ne.
Senior-Anwendungsentwickler vielleicht?
Hä?
Whatever.
Wir sehen, wir.
Benefits, Homeoffice.
Ja, das habe ich tatsächlich gehört, dass das dort recht gut funktioniert.
Senior-Alles-Enabler, ja.
Ähm.
Ach, da ist noch mal so ein Dreisteil.
Okay, also.
Aufgrund meiner Erfahrung mit meinem Ex-Kolleg, der dort arbeitet, kann ich sagen, der Laden ist nicht schlecht.
Die Stellenanzeige ist so semi-nice.
Aber wenn sich ein Kollege von dir dort bewerben will, dann soll er sich bewerben.
Der Laden ist nicht verkehrt von allem, was ich gehört habe.
Die Stellenanzeige ist halt pepega irgendwo.
Wisst ihr, was ich für einen Eindruck habe bei der Stellenanzeige?
Dass es eine Stellenanzeige ist, die intern geschaltet wurde, die für interne Besetzung geschrieben wurde.
Und man hat vergessen, als man keinen gefunden hat, diese Stellenanzeige umzuschreiben für nicht-interne Leute, dass die auch verstehen, was die eigentlich haben wollen.
So wirkt das ein bisschen auf mich.
Ja.
Maxi, findest du Scrum richtig gemacht?
Richtig gemacht ist das eine gute Sache.
Aber es wird selten richtig, äh, wird selten gut gemacht.
Es artet eher in irgendeine Glaubenssache aus, so nach dem Motto, okay, wenn wir uns jetzt eine Viertelstunde am Tag in Kreis stellen, ohne dass man sich dabei hinsetzt, sind wir auf einmal agil und viel produktiver.
Und solche Dinger.
Das macht dann natürlich keinen Sinn.
Wie gesagt, ich finde den Grundgedanken, der hinter dieser ganzen Agile-Sache steckt, oder zumindest das, was auch einer der...
Mitunterzeichner dieses ursprünglichen agilen Manifests und sowas, ja, was der sagt ist, und das finde ich tatsächlich gut, dass eine seiner Motivationsgründe für diese ganze Agilitätssache war, dass sich Entwickler weniger direkt mit dem Management auseinandersetzen müssen.
Und das finde ich sinnvoll.
Weil wenn du den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigt bist, hier, können wir das so machen, ach nee, ich hab's mir an.
So.
Ah, ich hab mit dem gesprochen, da musst du es so...
Da kriegst du es nicht so auf die Reihe.
Oder ah, jetzt müssen sie mal ganz schnell gucken, weil hier ist irgendwas...
Management-Orga-Sachen von den Entwicklern fernhalten und trotzdem den Leuten Einfluss nehmen, also Einflussmöglichkeiten geben auf das Projekt, weil letztendlich bezahlen die es ja auch.
Dafür ist...
Das ist ein guter Ansatz.
Wie das teilweise umgesetzt wird.
Und dass das oftmals auch schon tatsächlich so ein bisschen...
So eine Glaubensfrage ausartet, das finde ich dann wieder bescheuert.
Wisst ihr, was ich lustig finde?
Die ganzen Beratungsunternehmen haben ja ein Bullshit-Bingo drauf.
Und die verkaufen...
Also...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Die haben halt auch keine wirkliche Ahnung, was sie da so treiben.
Sondern die können gut verkaufen.
Und zwar, wo ich mal ein Beispiel dazu bringe.
In dem letzten Unternehmen, wo ich gearbeitet habe...
Hat uns irgendein Beratungsunternehmen, wollte uns verkaufen.
Also, da ging es ja darum so, wie soll das hier mit Prozessen und Strukturen, wie soll das alles neu ausgerichtet werden?
Ja, da haben die sich das von irgendeinem Beratungsunternehmen, so ein, wie nennt man das, so ein Konzept erarbeiten lassen.
Und da stand unter anderem drinnen...
Ich muss jetzt aufpassen, dass ich das jetzt doch richtig zusammenkriege.
In diesem Konzept stand unter anderem drinnen, mehr in Stellen denken, als in Personen.
So.
Und in dem Unternehmen, wo ich jetzt bin, die haben auch so ein Beratungsunternehmen am Start.
Und dort, das Beratungsunternehmen sagt, ja, eher, äh, nee, wie haben die gesagt?
Eher Köpfe als Stellen oder sowas.
Das ist halt...
Die verkaufen immer das, was gerade nicht da ist, um ihren Kram verkaufen zu können.
Also, das Allerwichtigste aus meiner Sicht ist, dass man Leute hat, die wissen, was sie machen.
In ihrem jeweiligen Bereich.
Und das ist deutlich weniger verbreitet, als man denkt.
Ich habe euch ja von meinem letzten Job erzählt, vom Java-Entwickler, der nicht Java programmieren konnte,
und vom Change-Koordinator, der keine Changes koordinieren wollte und sowas.
Wir sind alle ab und zu mal Low-Performer.
Außer die mit dem richtigen Grindset-Mindset natürlich, ja.
Die in der Gruppe sind, die nicht.
Aber, ich finde es nicht schlimm, wenn Leute es auch mal ruhig angehen lassen.
Was ich viel entscheidender finde, ist, dass die Sachen, die sie machen, durchdacht sind.
Und mir ist es lieber, einer ist kein, wie heißt das?
Ja doch, hier, 10 times Developer oder whatever, ja.
Mir ist das lieber, einer ist faul.
Und...
Also, ich spreche da aus Erfahrung, ja.
Mir ist es lieber, jemand ist faul,
aber das, was rauskommt, funktioniert.
Und bei faulen Leuten ist die Chance, dass es was rauskommt, wenn sie was gemacht haben, dass es funktioniert, höher.
Weil, die wollen sich ja nie wieder damit beschäftigen müssen.
Da gibt es sogar Untersuchungen zu.
Also, faule Leute sind richtig gut da drin,
Sachen überlegt, um zu...
Obwohl sie faul sind.
Die finden genau die richtige Balance aus Einsatz und es muss aber gut sein, dass ich mich danach nie wieder damit beschäftigen muss.
Und sobald du anfängst, natürlich, die Leute zu überlasten, da kommt nichts Gescheites mehr raus.
Ich habe mal einen Vortrag gesehen, das habe ich euch, glaube ich, schon mal gezeigt.
Aber, ich habe mal einen Vortrag gesehen, das fand ich echt gut gemacht.
Und zwar, der hat so eine Tabelle gemalt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das überhaupt aus dem Kopf noch zusammenkriege.
Der hatte irgendwie so eine Tabelle gemalt.
Und zwar...
Wie war das nochmal?
So, die Spalte war irgendwie...
Hat Ahnung?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich es richtig...
Hat keine Ahnung?
Und dann gab es noch irgendwie...
Ja, meine Tabellenskills sind ganz, ganz toll.
Und dann gab es noch...
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Super motiviert und dann gab es noch irgendwie unmotiviert.
Ich glaube, so war das, wie er das gezeigt hat.
Und dann meinte er so, ey, was sind eigentlich Mitarbeiter, die man haben möchte?
Und, ja, klar, jemand, der Ahnung hat, super motiviert ist und super krassen Arbeitsoutput hat,
das sind so die, so die, ja, wie nennt man das?
So die herausstechenden Leute, da gibt es nicht so viele von,
aber die muss man sich warm halten.
Das sind so quasi, wie hat man zu Ruby-Zeiten früher gesagt, die Rockstar-Developer.
Aber die muss man sich warm halten.
Also die will man auf jeden Fall haben, ja.
Die will man auf jeden Fall haben.
Hat Ahnung und ist unmotiviert.
Den will man auch haben.
Weil unmotivierte Leute, beziehungsweise unmotiviert ist,
aber wir sollten nicht unmotiviert sagen, wir sollten wirklich sagen, faule Leute.
Das trifft es in dem Fall besser als unmotiviert.
Faul, okay?
Faule Leute mit Ahnung will man auch haben.
Er hat gemeint, übrigens, faule Leute, die Übersicht haben, sind auch super Führungskräfte,
weil die können gut delegieren.
Faule Leute mit Ahnung will man auch haben,
weil faule Leute mit Ahnung oftmals ziemlich gute Lösungen erarbeiten,
sodass sie später nicht mehr sich drum kümmern müssen, weil es einfach funktioniert.
Also das will man auch haben.
Dann gibt es noch die Kombination faul und hat keine Ahnung.
Da kann man eventuell auch den einen oder anderen noch ertragen von.
Aber was geht?
Ganz Schlimmes.
Und was du auf gar keinen Fall haben willst, ist einer, der super motiviert ist und keine Ahnung hat.
Warum?
Weil er dir alles kaputt macht.
Dein kein Plan, was er macht, ist überall mit dabei, macht alle Leute verrückt und macht alles nur noch schlimmer.
Also das sind die Schlimmsten, die willst du auf gar keinen Fall haben.
Und das habe ich in irgendeinem YouTube-Konferenz.
Talk gesehen.
Und ich finde, da ist echt einiges Wahres dran an dieser Tabelle, die er da gezeigt hat.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich sie richtig zusammenbekommen habe jetzt.
Aber kommt zum großen und ganzen hin.
Und das fand ich echt treffend, ja.
Hiervon gibt es wenige, hiervon gibt es wenige, ja.
Die Ahnung haben und super motiviert sind.
Da hast du natürlich, das ist natürlich Goldgrube für dich, wenn du so jemand hast.
Ja, Ahnung und faul ist auch gut.
Ja.
Wenn er was macht, kannst du dich eigentlich darauf verlassen, dass er sich durchdacht.
Das hier würde ich mal fast sagen, das hier ist entgegen dem, was in jeder Stellenanzeige steht, ja.
Ich würde mal behaupten, das hier ist ein Großteil der IT-Leute.
Der gescheiten IT-Leute, ja.
Das hier ist ein Großteil.
Ich kenne sehr viele IT-Leute, die wirklich super schlau sind, aber faul ist fuck.
Ob ich super schlau bin, kann ich persönlich nicht beurteilen.
Eher nicht.
Aber ich bin faul.
Und ich überlege mir auch immer zweimal, wenn ich was gebaut habe, okay, funktioniert der Scheiß gut genug, dass es mir nie wieder auf den Sack geht.
Und nur dann benutze ich es, beziehungsweise, oder nur dann sage ich, es ist fertig jetzt.
Und das andere passt ja auch, ne.
Und selbst wenn du jemanden hast, der keine Ahnung hat und faul ist, das kann ja durchaus auch was Gutes sein, ja.
Vielleicht brauchst du jemanden im Team, der einfach nur gut für den Zusammenhalt ist.
Ja, faule Leute sind auch super im Sachenautomatisieren, das ist richtig, genau.
Vielleicht brauchst du einfach, der nur richtig gut so für den Team-Spirit ist.
Das kann durchaus auch so jemand sein.
Was du halt gar nicht haben willst, ist das.
Ja, das habe ich schon mal gezeigt vor einer Weile, ja.
Da habe ich es in Notepad gemacht.
Motiviert keine Ahnung und Produktionsdatenbank-Access.
Genau das ist das Problem bei sowas, ja.
Du hast am Endeffekt mit so einem Team, der nicht so gut ist, dass du nicht so gut bist.
Mit so Leuten hast du nur Stress und nur Probleme.
Also ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Dozent ist, aber Anwendungsentwickler und Excel passt nicht so wirklich zusammen.
Weil man kann Excel-Anwendungen entwickeln, aber es ist nicht so, dass die meisten Anwendungen in Excel entwickelt würden.
Also das ist Blödsinn.
Ja, tut so, als hätte er Ahnung, ist hier auch sehr oft zu finden.
Und wenn du selbst vor einem Thema überhaupt keine Ahnung hast, dann ist das nicht so.
Wenn du selbst keine Ahnung hast, ist es auch schwierig.
Deswegen habe ich meinem Chef empfohlen, ob er nicht Set-Server benutzen will als Test, wenn er neue Linux-Leute einstellt.
Einfach die Easy-Tests mal 1, 2 machen lassen und dann weißt du schon Bescheid, ob der grundlegend Ahnung von Linux hat.
Weil die Easy-Sachen bei Set-Server, die sind wirklich so easy, dass du die auch unter Anspannung in ein Vorstellungsgespräch hinkriegst.
Und was ich natürlich auch hoffe.
Dass der vielleicht, dass wir vielleicht ein Premium-Abo kaufen für Set-Servers.
Weil der Typ hat das auf jeden Fall verdient.
Gerade von YouTube her rübergestolpert. Nice.
Ja, Set-Servers, das meine ich.
Nicht Sadamusein. Set-Servers.
Einer, die Google suche manchmal.
Ja, traurig. Set. Set-Servers.
Ja, da gibt es verschiedene Übungen, die man machen kann.
Auf AWS-VM sind das, glaube ich.
Kriegst du in der AWS-VM professioniert, musst das Problem lösen und du kriegst am Ende auch angezeigt, ob das passt oder nicht.
Und die Easy-Challenges, die sind wirklich easy.
Das sollte jeder, gerade die ersten 5 oder so, das sollte jeder, der Linux-Erfahrung hat und sich um einen Linux-Shop bewirbt,
auch unter Anspannung von einem Vorstellungsgespräch hinkriegen.
Gerade das Erste, das ist wirklich super easy.
Leute, kurz auf mein Handy gucken, nicht, dass es irgendeinen Rufbereitschaftseinsatz oder so gab.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Ich bin müde.
Bettge, korrekt.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen.
Es wird Zeit.
Ich habe schon lange kein Gute-Nacht-Gespräch.
Ich habe schon lange kein Gute-Nacht-Song mehr gespielt im Stream.
Aber YouTube entfernt den ja auch immer.
Wie zufrieden seid ihr eigentlich mit Single 4?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde es jetzt weder gut noch schlecht.
Es spricht wahrscheinlich für das Tool, dass ich gar nicht so oft dran denke,
was ja für so ein Signal- bzw. Alarmierungsservice eigentlich ein ganz gutes...
Nee, ich meinte das gar nicht.
Ich habe wirklich nachgedacht.
Nee, nee.
Ähm, das ist nicht als schlecht zu werten.
Es geht einfach, ja.
Ich hatte damit jetzt noch keine Probleme.
Es...
Ich habe mich da...
Ich bin seit zehn Wochen am Stück schon on duty in Signal 4.
Ich habe mich da einmal eingeloggt und seitdem geht es halt einfach.
Und wenn was ist, klingelt das Handy.
Fertig.
Es macht das, was es soll.
Das Webinterface finde ich ein bisschen sehr mittelalterlich, was man ja auch schon sieht,
wenn man auf die Webseite geht.
Das Erste, was runtergeladen wird, ist jQuery.
Das hat relativ viel Unterstützung.
Das Erste ist, wenn du auf die Webseite kommst, jQuery.
Also das Webinterface sieht sehr...
Ja, als...
Als wurde es vielleicht von Leuten erstellt, die nicht hauptsächlich Webentwickler sind.
Aber der Rest ist solide und funktioniert.
Es wäre vielleicht jetzt meine...
Nicht meine persönliche erste Wahl.
Für so einen Notification-Service gewesen, wenn ich mich da schlau gemacht hätte.
Aber es ist okay.
Es tut, was es soll.
Ich verwende keine Spezialfeatures davon.
Ja, also wir machen da keine Schichtplanung drüber oder sowas.
Es ist einfach nur, solange man sich eingeloggt hat, klingelt das Handy bei einem Alert.
Wenn man sich ausgeloggt hat, nicht.
Datadog ist ganz einfach.
Ganz nice.
Ja, weißt du, wofür Datadog auch noch ganz nice ist?
Ups, falsches E-Mode.
Datadog ist auch super nice zum Geld verbrennen.
SAP UI 5...
Moment, Moment, heißt das jetzt nicht...
Fiori oder sowas?
Haben wir nicht letztens gelernt, SAP UI heißt jetzt...
Fiori?
Wie hieß das?
Ich hab's schon wieder...
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, oder?
Doch, Fiori, ja, ja, ja.
Siehste mal, kann ich in meine Skill-Liste gleich mal SAP aufnehmen.
Ich kann ein Wort erwähnen und alle denken, ich hab Ahnung von.
Manchmal muss das auch sein.
Herr Endpunkt konnte das richtig gut.
Wenn ich mal irgendwann zufälligerweise Eindruck machen möchte bei SAP-Entwicklern,
da sag ich, ja, SAP UI, ihr Kack-Noobs, wir machen schon Fiori-Apps.
Dann sagen die alle, boah, Alter, sind die advanced.
Die kennen sich ja voll aus.
Pockers, sagen die dann.
Ich sag, ihr seid richtig...
Pockers.
Ich hab's einmal bisher nur geschafft, dass jemand auf der Arbeit Pockers gesagt hat.
Die Story hab ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Nicht in meinem aktuellen Job, aber im letzten hab ich's mal geschafft,
dass einer auf einer offiziellen Präsentation vor, keine Ahnung, 120 Leuten gesagt hat, Pockers.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, da war auch Twitch zufrieden.
Nicht bei mir, nicht bei mir, so allgemein Twitch.
Weil ansonsten würde niemand Pockers einfach aussprechen auf so einer Präsentation.
Ja, klar, mit dem hab ich letzten sogar mal telefoniert.
Ich hab's aber schon wieder vergessen, was er jetzt macht.
Er macht irgendwas anderes, ist nicht mehr dort, was er in meinem Video erzählt hat und macht jetzt auch Big Stonks.
Eigentlich müsste ich mit Herr Endpunkt mal wieder was aufnehmen, so nach dem Motto,
Mein Ex-Azubi, 10 Jahre später oder so.
Der ist ja auch schon jetzt eine ganze Weile fertig.
10 Jahre ist er noch nicht fertig.
Aber bald.
Der dürfte bald bestimmt auch 10 Jahre oder so fertig sein.
Das wirst du echt mal...
Mein Ex-Azubi packt aus, 10 Jahre später.
Wenn's nach mir geht, also wenn ich...
Ich hab da schon immer ein paar blöde Sachen drin, ne?
Was ich geil fand, ne?
Letzter Laden, wo ich war,
hatte ich...
Emojis drinnen.
Irgendwelche anderen blöden Meme-Bildchen ab und zu.
Aber nur, wenn's gepasst hat, jetzt nicht total übertrieben oder so.
Und am Ende von der Präsentation...
Das Einzige, was ihnen aufgefallen ist...
Also, ich lass die ja immer ein bisschen Probe gucken davor, ja?
Was den Probe-Guckern aufgefallen ist...
...dass das...
Also, niemand hat was gesagt über irgendwelche Meme-Bildchen
oder über irgendwelche blöden Emojis oder so in der Präsentation.
Niemand, ja?
Das, was die gesagt haben, ist nur...
Oh, da fehlt aber das Logo von der Firma drin.
Das ist kein Corporate Design, die PowerPoint-Vorlage gewesen.
Sagt, ja, ich hab keine Corporate Design-Vorlage genommen.
Ja, das geht ja nicht.
Das muss Corporate Design-Vorlage sein.
Wenn man sonst keine Probleme hat, ist der...
Du kannst ein Emoji über die ganze Seite stretchen, das ist egal.
Aber...
Wenn im Hintergrund nicht die Corporate Design-Powerpoint-Vorlage zu sehen ist, dann ist vorbei.
Ja, im jetzigen Laden durfte ich noch keine Präsi halten.
Beziehungsweise, ich durfte schon, ich hab's aber noch nicht fertig gekriegt.
Ich darf sogar mehrere machen, wenn ich's mal fertig kriege.
Ich darf was halten zu Linux-Containern.
So, ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Zu drei Sachen.
Zu drei Sachen hab ich, ähm...
Das...
Okay, quasi, das zu machen.
Linux-Container?
Ah, hab ich's noch am CD, ja.
Ähm...
Terraform und Git, glaub ich, war das?
Ich hab's schon wieder verdrängt.
Hab's mir aufgeschrieben.
Ich wollte mit der Linux-Container-Geschichte...
Achso, und bestimmt auch ein bisschen Cloud- und Kubernetes-Zeug.
Ähm...
Ich wollte mit der Linux-Container-Vorstellung da mal eigentlich anfangen.
Gerade halt auch für Leute, die damit noch nicht so viel zu tun haben.
Aber ich krieg's einfach zeitlich nicht hin.
Und ich seh's nicht ein, das privat zu erstellen, wenn's für die Firma ist.
So, aber jetzt...
Ich wollt schon vor zehn Minuten auf.
Schön, dass ihr da gewesen seid.
Chat, wir sehen uns die Tage wieder.
Dann machen wir auch was im Stream.
Heute war Schwätz-Only.
Bad Git-Time jetzt.
Alles klar.
Wir hören uns bis dann. Macht's gut, CEO.